[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a closer look inside the alleged sarah
lawrence college sex cult can i get up
now
plus a victim's family member takes the
stand in the trial of ex-icu doctor
william hussell i didn't understand how
we got from stable
to the icu for continued care to
he's dead he's dead we should just pull
the plug and 62 years after her remains
were found the so-called little miss
nobody is identified but first the
murder of nba star lorenzen wright it
took an evil heart
to do this
there's no way to sit up and say
something bad about lorenzo right this
case ain't about him
this case is about billy ray turner more
than a decade later accused killer billy
ray turner stands trial long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin more than a decade after the
murder of famed nba player lorenzen
wright opening statements are presented
in the trial of his accused murderer
billy ray turner faces multiple charges
including first degree murder in
wright's 2010 death prosecutors say
wright's ex-wife cheryl wright recruited
turner to shoot and kill her husband
they say shara wright was after her
husband's two million dollar life
insurance policy lorenzen wright's body
was discovered in tennessee in 2010.
seven years later the murder weapon was
recovered in a mississippi lake sarah
wright was later charged in her
ex-husband's murder she's currently
serving a 30-year sentence after
accepting a plea deal to facilitating
murder in opening statements on tuesday
prosecutors pointed the finger at shara
wright but said turner is still guilty
of the crime
evil in the heart
it took an evil heart
to do this
and i'm not talking
about billy turner's heart
i'm not talking about him
it took a particularly
evil heart
one that was filled with
jealousy with desperation
with hurt
with greed
and literally
two
millionaire
reasons
to want him
deaf
i'm talking about sheriff
wright
lorenzen's
ex-wife
turner's defense attorneys followed
dropping a racial slur in the defense's
opening statements
the desperation in here is so clear that
that
that i really don't know
what to expect i know that they're gonna
probably bring somebody who says
billy i'm sitting over to jail watching
this waiting on this day to get before
y'all
say it
man share a plan
i shot that for her
i expect that to be said
but before you make your decision up on
that
wait till you hear the rebuttal side of
that there's no way to sit up and say
something bad about the wrenching right
it's a great guy
this case with all due respect to his
family and his friends and his
fraternity brothers and and his close
loved ones
this case ain't about him this case is
about billy ray turner
joining us today to discuss opening
statements in billy ray turner's trial
is legal analyst dina dahl and terry
austin dina what's connecting turner to
wright's murder and is cheryl a reliable
witness to say that wright was involved
essentially what is connecting him are
his two co-conspirators one indicted
which is shara and the second one jimmy
martin which was not indicted those two
are the ones that gave information to
the police that prosecution is using
jimmy said where the weapon was found
and said that you know billy ray turner
was the one that used the weapon
all three of them planned this as a way
of gaining his insurance money the
prosecution said but there isn't a lot
of like other evidence that connects
them so whether or not the jury believe
these witnesses or think that these are
self-serving statements on them is
really what will decide this trial yeah
it seems like reliability is at the
heart of this case we'll see how that
plays out terri you watch the opening
statements in this case what are your
thoughts about the openings
well i thought the prosecution as you
saw in that clip was very slow but at
least he was deliberate he was a little
bit soft-spoken i think the jury was
probably straining to hear what he had
to say but it was logical it was
sequential the opening that i thought
was the worst defense opening i think
i've ever heard bar none was the defense
opening in this case john keith perry is
his name
and he was rambling he was confusing he
was mentioning names and not connecting
those names to who those people were and
he basically confused the jury the other
thing is he used language that was
offensive you saw in that clip he even
used the n-word and i've never ever seen
an attorney do that and and frankly i
thought we would get an objection but we
didn't so we'll see how the case goes he
probably shouldn't have done an opening
at all yeah maybe confusion is his
tactic in this case of course see how
that plays out in covering this case law
and crime network for capital gavel
coverage
now the man accused of shooting at least
five homeless people between washington
dc and new york city is taken into
custody law and crime daily first
brought you this story earlier this week
as police search for this man wanted in
multiple attacks two of which ended in
murder on tuesday police announced 30
year old gerald brevard the third was
taken into custody in washington d.c
investors say brevard
has a history of misdemeanors felonies
and mental health issues officials
believe the attacks happened between
march 3rd and 12th as brevard targeted
homeless people in both washington d.c
and new york
and the arrest for another incident that
happened in new york a man is taken into
custody in philadelphia tuesday morning
for allegedly stabbing two workers at
the museum of modern art in manhattan
new york over the weekend investigators
say gary cavanagh got upset over his
membership to the museum being revoked
before jumping the counter and attacking
several of the workers a man and a woman
were stabbed and taken to the hospital
they're expected to be okay police say
he faces charges in the stabbings but
they say he will also be charged for
starting a fire in a hotel room out of
best western on monday which caused
extensive damage police say they found
cabanas sleeping on a bench near a bus
station tuesday morning when they took
him into custody
still ahead on law and crime daily a
victim's family member takes the stand
as an ex-icu doctor is on trial for the
murder of multiple patients but first
little miss nobody no more six decades
after a young girl's remains are
discovered arizona authorities identify
the victim
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube
you can now get the live law and crime
network with youtube tv for all of your
daily live trial coverage legal news
expert analysis and original true crime
programs subscribe to youtube tv today
and then locate lawn crime in the
channel guide and for only 1.99 a month
you can add the network to your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily 62
years after a girl's body is found in
arizona detectives can finally name her
thanks to dna technology law and crime's
angela levy is here with the sad story
of sharon lee gallegos
brian this is incredibly sad for 62
years sharon lee gallegos was referred
to as little miss nobody her identity
was a mystery until dna technology was
used to identify her along with genetic
testing now yavapai county sheriff's
officials held a press conference
tuesday morning to discuss the work that
was done to identify sharon she was just
four years old going on five when she
was kidnapped from the backyard of her
grandmother's home in alma gorda new
mexico on july 21
1960. sheriff's officials say a man
looking for rocks found her partially
buried body 11 days later that's about
eight and a half hours away near
prescott arizona othrum labs conducted
dna testing analysis on the remains
which led to the positive identification
we still have work to do in this case we
would still like to identify the people
who took her
we would still like to be able to answer
the questions
what happened in those 10 days from the
time she was taken to the time she was
found
so we are still working we have
detective scott perry here today uh
detective perry
and our volunteer investigator deborah
west have been hard of work on that ever
since we got this name and they continue
to work on that
and we're hoping that maybe somebody
today
might see this and might have some
information about that july 21st day in
alabama new mexico and what happened
and the sheriff says they are
particularly interested in speaking to
two children who may have been in the
car carrying the man and woman who
kidnapped sharon
that was believed to be either a green
dodge or chrysler model car that was
from the 1950s now police believe at the
time that the white man and white woman
who were in that car had actually been
stalking sharon for about a week before
they abducted her brian
thanks again back to break down new
information in the case of little miss
nobody no more is legal analyst dina
doll and terry austin terry did the
presser answer all of your questions or
are there still some mysteries to be
solved
i've got to say brian i still have so
many questions based on that presser it
was about an hour long which is pretty
long for that type of presser they
talked a very long time about how
difficult it was to identify remains
back during the 60s and that is the
reason why it took so long with all of
the dna that they now have and the
techniques that they now have but i
still want to know what was her exact
cause of death and i think great that
the family now has some closure as far
as who she was but they don't know how
she died and they don't know who killed
her so they still have a lot of work to
do and the other question that i have is
why did they name her little miss nobody
they could have given her a name like
you know the little angel or something
to that effect i just think it says such
a negative connotation they did give her
a burial and they did say some words and
they did have 70 mourners come to her
funeral so i think that was good yeah
now dina
terry kind of touched on this a bit but
what does this presser tell us about the
advances in dna and the closure that it
can bring to families
over 60 years later
it's pretty amazing because she was
found 10 days after
now we know she disappeared you would
think that maybe they could have tied it
back then but what they did back then
was compare the footprints of the
remains that they found with this
disappeared girl and they determined
that they didn't match that and they had
the age wrong they thought their remains
were about seven years old and she was
in fact four so it goes to show how
important it is the tools that we use or
you know prosecutors law enforcement use
to evaluate the evidence that they
received the fact that we are now you
know in this advanced dna world the same
remains and the same facts have a
completely different result absolutely
no angel what do we know about the
circumstances surrounding sharon's
disappearance
well you know very little you know as i
mentioned we had uh there was this
couple in a green car
and they had uh abducted her and offered
her candy apparently and to buy her
clothes and she said no and then her
cousin said that she was actually
snatched there out of the alleyway
in its incredibly sad case her nephew
who would have been or sharon's nephew
was there today and he says it's not
clear yet whether or not they'll decide
to take her remains back to arizona or
leave them there in new mexico
where the community came together to
bury her back so many years ago
interesting thank you angie for the
update and thank you both terry and dina
for your contribution coming up on law
and crime daily we head to federal court
where the accused sarah lawrence sex
call leader stands trial plus patient
comfort or cold-blooded murderer for the
first time we're hearing from victims
family members in the case of ex-icu
doctor william hussell
[Music]
welcome back we continue to follow a
case involving the deaths of over a
dozen people in columbus ohio as a
former doctor faces murder charges for
allegedly killing his patients on
tuesday for the first time jurors heard
from family members of the alleged
victims william hussell is accused of
giving 14 patients excessive amounts of
fentanyl and other drugs between 2015
and 2018. prosecutors allege that led to
their deaths his defense team argues he
was giving end-of-life care over the
last two weeks juris had only heard from
medical professionals including
pharmacists nurses and other physicians
some of whom worked alongside hussel on
tuesday an alleged victim's
step-daughter took the stand maria
havens now works in health care and was
in nursing school in 2018. she told the
jury what happened the night her
stepfather died
what happened once you walked into the
room
it's very vivid so i remember standing
at the edge of troy's bed and my mom was
to my right william hussell
was off to my uh left and he
said
that he was 99.9 sure that troy was in
total organ failure william husel said
he could give troy something to make him
comfortable and remove the tube
anyone tell you what medication they
were going to be giving troy no
did they tell you how much of any
medications they'd be giving him no
i could make somewhat sense of what he
what was being
told to us
but i didn't understand how we got from
stable
to the icu for continued care to
he's dead he's dead we should just pull
the plug
hindsight 2020 i wish i would have
said something
um but i think maybe at that moment i
wasn't feeling as
medically knowledgeable and and felt
more like a stepdaughter trusting this
provider but i didn't understand exactly
how we got there
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin join us again as you dive
in to the alleged deadly doctor terry
the testimony in the case has turned
from medical to personal uh how do you
imagine that's changing the trial and
even the kind of like environments in
the courtroom
you know what i think that was a poor
strategy on the part of the prosecution
they should have in my opinion put the
parties first put the victims first put
the individuals who have a personal
connection because that way you can get
the jury to understand the emotion
behind the case when you put on the
medical professionals first sometimes it
glosses over the eyes of the jury not
only that but if they had heard the
people who were affected first it might
actually affect how they look at those
doctors because remember those doctors
and nurses really do relate to the
defendant they relate to health because
they've made those decisions themselves
and if you saw the family first you
might think are you being credible so i
think it was a poor strategy yeah now
dina was there anything in the direct of
this witness that made you think who
sells a murderer and not giving comfort
care
i think one of the most crucial things
that she said was that another doctor
had told the family not that long before
that he was stable so he goes from
stable to organ failure within a very
short period of time and so you know
we've his defense has always been he was
trying to comfort them this i think was
the first kind of piece of evidence that
might go to a little bit more of a
malicious um acting on his part if so i
thought that was useful for her and
remember these 14 um he's you know
charged with 14 deaths they each have to
be proved so this is also just very
helpful for this particular victim that
he hastened his death yeah and it's
interesting that this is not only a
witness in the sense that this is a
family member but she also has a bit of
medical knowledge as well so i think the
prosecution would be smart to kind of
double dip on this witness to help the
prosecution push towards that goal of
guilty now when we come back the accused
sarah lawrence college cult leader
stands trial in federal court we show
you the disturbing video of life inside
the notorious cult that's next on law on
crime daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
sarah lawrence column sex call trial is
delayed twice on tuesday as accused cult
leader lawrence ray suffers back-to-back
seizures
court was delayed tuesday morning after
rey suffered a seizure while being held
in a brooklyn jail the trial paused
again tuesday afternoon when he suffered
another seizure ray faces 17 charges
including racketeering and sex
trafficking charges among others all
this stands from allegations dating back
to 2010 when prosecutors say ray moved
in with his daughter who was a student
at sarah lawrence college officials say
ray befriended several students and
abused them for upwards of 10 years
prosecutors say he extorted money from
the students forced him into sex and
prostitution and even held manipulative
therapy sessions this week jurors were
shown one of rey's personal recordings
showing what appears to be one of the
therapy sessions
i want to get out stop making noise
stop making yes stop okay this is how
much you love me huh yes yeah clearly
happy number five
this is going on for like
just about seven hours snap to seven
hours
non-stop
non-stop
everything that comes out of her mouth
everything she says is a lie
yes
and it's really to deceive
federal jurors were shown that
disturbing video this week and also her
testimony that ray made some of his
victims wear diapers does this sort of
evidence
really push the needle for the
prosecution's case
absolutely i mean the video itself we
can hear him he knows what's happening
this is exactly what the expert from
talked about in the case this the
grooming the coercion and and we're so
the jurors are seeing that in in real
time and then also the the details about
the diapers i mean this case comes down
to credibility right he said versus kind
of they said and so all that video as
detailed as they can get makes their um
testimony much more believable to the
jury yeah especially when you're looking
at they're like i'm sorry like you see
this young man slapping himself in the
face there's no other excuse for other
reason than i think what the
prosecution's putting forward in this
case now terry the trial has been
delayed twice now because ray has had
two seizures do you think it's possible
the trial could be suspended because of
his health issues
you know that's a distinct possibility
but i hope that is not the case we know
that this alleged behavior began way
back in 2010 that's a long time ago
we're finally getting this case to trial
and you know if we have a further delay
if in fact he is ill and can't be
prosecuted then there's never going to
be any justice here having two seizures
in one day is quite a bit of medical
emergency and we very well could see
that they're going to have to suspend
the trial until he has his health back
so we'll see what happens but frankly he
was taken out on a stretcher and he
looked as though he was really in some
medical distress so hopefully the trial
will be able to continue yeah we've seen
some long delays uh don't forget the
robert durst trial some cases with covid
that have caused delays so maybe that
happens here in the lawrence raid trial
maybe a week delay maybe less than that
but we'll see how that goes and of
course give you updates here along crime
daily dina terry thank you as always and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
you discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you